So, I will discuss systemic mastocytosis 2026 updates.
These are my disclosures.
So, KIT inhibitors in mastocytosis, currently in 2026, we have midostorin and evapritinib,
FDA approved for advanced SM, imatinib is FDA approved for KIT, the H16 negative aggressive
SM, and evapritinib is FDA approved in indolent SM.
What will happen later this year or early next year could be, bizuclastinib could be
approved in ISM, indolent SM, smoldering SM, and advanced SM.
This is the data from midostorin led by Dr. Gottlieb.
What I want to focus on is the median survival patients were treated with midostorin was
around three years.
Is there still a role for midostorin in 2026?
Yes, in patients who have a C-finding and thrombocytopenia or high risk of intracranial
bleeding, someone on warfarin, for example, otherwise, I think evapritinib is the first
line.
During ASH, there was an update on the pathfinder study of evapritinib.
This is the phase two study starting at a dose of 200 milligram, and you will see from
the update, the median duration of response here is around 57 months, 58 months.
And when you look at the data after maturing, you will see more CR and CR with incomplete
hematologic recovery of around 30 percent, and the overall survival of the whole population
previously treated or treatment naive was around five years, whereas it was not reached
in patients who were treatment naive.
Side effect profile with the update, it is what we know about evapritinib, cytopenias,
you will see in those patients, edema, and there was the cognitive disorder, like difficulty
naming things, for example, was seen in 18 percent, and it was grade three and around
5 percent.
Hair color changes were seen in 17 percent of patients.
I think that's a good thing.
Thank you very much.
I tried to compare Explorer to Pathfinder.
Explorer was the phase one where the patients had higher doses of evapritinib, and you will
see with the lower dose, when you start at 200 and then go to 100, when patients achieve
a response, cognitive effects decreased from 30 to 18 percent, hair color changes went
down from 26 to 17 percent, CNS bleeding risk was lower from 13 to 3.7 percent.
Also, Pathfinder was addended, there was an amendment to the protocol that patients below
the, with the platelets below the level of 50, they were not allowed to enroll.
Also diarrhea decreased.
There was progression in 14 percent of patients, mainly in patients with an associated myeloid
neoplasm, and the progression was to acute leukemia, and there was a recent poster at
ASH by Dr. Ben Cransell that showed in vitro mass cells suppress monocyte growth, and when,
and this suppression is released with ADN.
Okay.
So, in the future, we'll see, will second generation kit inhibitors be tolerated when
combined with HMA?
We don't know the answer yet.
Evapritinib and indolent SM, we know the data, the dose is 25 milligram, that led to the
FDA approval, and there was a recent three-year update during ASH, and there were no intracranial
bleeding seen with the lower doses.
And the cognitive adverse events were reported at 8 percent.
There were grade one to two LFT abnormalities in 9 percent.
There were four major changes in 4 percent.
But what's interesting, 29 percent of patients needed to up titrate to 50 milligram.
There was another abstract that showed when you follow up, when these patients would follow
up, there were no kit resistance mutations detected on serial sampling.
What about bisuclastinib, the new kid on the block?
So it's an oral selective kit inhibitor with minimal brain penetration.
So there are two studies, the SUMMIT and non-advanced SM, and ISM and smoldering SM, using a dose
of 100 milligram, which is lower than the dose used in the ADN.
And the APICS trial in advanced SM, which is 150 milligram.
So during ASH, we had an update on the SUMMIT and ISM and SSM, around six or seven percent
of the patients had smoldering SM.
And the trial met its endpoint of improved symptoms.
So the placebo, there was a decrease of 15 points in the symptom score, whereas it was
24 points with bisuclastinib.
When I try to compare, it's always like from fellowship, don't compare trials head to head,
like if they are not randomized, but if you look at the graphs, maybe there is an earlier
response, earlier improvement in symptoms with bisuclastinib.
When you look at the symptom improvement, maybe also when you compare it to evapritinib,
maybe there's a little bit more improvement in the cognitive symptoms that happen in ISM.
You will see very nice waterfall plots.
What's interesting in evapritinib and bisuclastinib, the objective measures, they improve much
more than you see with the symptoms.
So that's interesting.
We don't know the reason why, but very nice improvement in mast cell burden, tryptase,
epinephrine.
We don't know the reason why, but very nice improvement.
So that's interesting.
We don't know the reason why, but very nice improvement in the symptoms.
These are my accomplishments, and thank you, Amit, on time.